[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne rêve plus histoire je suis seul
sans toi je suis là sans toi je suis
comme un orphelin dans un dortoir
je n'ai plus envie de vivre ma vie
la vie c'est ce score
tu parles je n'ai plus de vie
et même mon lit
se transforme en quai de gare
tu t'en vas je suis
voilà
complètement bala
[Musique]
quand ma mère sortent elles soient
call me laisser seul m'avait
mon désert moi je suis là
[Musique]
mallat
arrive on ne sait jamais quand
par on ne sait jamais l'isu
et ça va faire bientôt deux ans
je
un rocher
on a péché
tous accrochés à toi
si fatigué
je suis épuisé
semblant de
quand ils sont lâches boivent toutes les
nuits et tous les whisky
moi ont le même goût et tous les bateaux
ont eu ton drapeau
je me sais plus où aller tuer partout je
suis malade
complètement balle
2 je vais le second sens dans ton pas et
je suis
face aux morts
en toiture
ces malades
ça
je suis pas là
les sens
[Musique]
pourtant pas
j'ai vu du talent
avant ta peau cet amour me tue si ça
continue
je crèverai seul avec moi les thomas
radio comme un gosse idiot écoute on a
pour pouvoir qui chantera je suis mal à
2 pleinement à la deûle
quand ma mère sortent et le soir
eyquem laisser soeur la mère
désespoir
[Musique]
c'est ça
je suis là
d
ça
j'ai le coeur
le mans
allah
c'est par là
[Musique]